&gt;&gt; So, Greg, I was looking at neuroplasticity, and how learning physical changes
our brain. And I was trying to find a really good example of that, and then I
came across the example you used in your book about London cab drivers. Can you
give us a little bit about that setting?
&gt;&gt; Sure. Sure. I'd be glad to. So, yeah, neuroscientists decided to study this one
group that really is intensively involved in learning. They can't use any other
map. They can't use a physical map, they can't use GPS so, you really, truly
have to learn this very complicated network of streets. And, it takes months
and months. And they have to pass a very difficult exam. And then, for a
comparison group, they chose another group that did a lot of driving. So, they
didn't want to explain any differences by driving alone. So they pick bus
drivers. Now, the thing about bus driver is that they don't really have to
learn a whole lot. They take the same route every day and so on. So, when they
look at the hippocampus of these two groups, brain region involved in learning
and memory. The hippocampus of the cab drivers was a lot more complex and rich,
and bigger actually, then the bus drivers. So, this is just another great
example then, of how learning really does change the brain.
&gt;&gt; I'm really glad that you mentioned the hippocampus and learning because we're
actually going to go into talking about the brain structures now. So, thank you
a lot for giving us that example.